inzwischen aber sehen wir hier das also
die aktuelle stunde ihre schatten voraus
wirft seehofer bundesinnenminister um
den es gehen wird
seine parteifreundin dorothea bär
die fdp hat diese aktuelle stunde
beantragt und das interessante daran ist
dass über ein thema geredet wird dass
kaum einer kennt es geht um den
masterplan migration aus dem hause von
horst seehofer dieser masterplan ist
aber nicht publiziert worden einige
wenige kennen sie in der csu auch die
bundeskanzlerin kennt sie aber die
wenigsten der abgeordneten die jetzt
gleich darüber sprechen werden sie
wissen dass dieser masterplan migration
gestern vor allem wellen geschlagen hat
insofern als als es zum krach innerhalb
der unionsfraktion über einen punkt
dabei gekommen ist nämlich den punkt
darf man darf man flüchtende an der
grenze direkt ab weisen wenn sich schon
in einem anderen land ein asylantrag
gestellt haben
oder darf man das nicht das erste war
die seehofer position das zweite die
merkel position einer von 64 punkten
dieses masterplans ist also strittig was
die anderen 63 punkte sind weiß wie
gesagt keiner so genau
vielleicht sind wir in einer stunde
schlauer wenn diese aktuelle stunde hier
gleich zu ende sein wird
sie waren auf der seite der mehrheit des
hauses da die fdp diese aktuelle stunde
beantragt hat hat sie auch das recht als
erste zu reden
horst seehofer der sich hier vielleicht
gerade auf dem smartphone noch mal den
masterplan in erinnerung rufen es ist
also jetzt der erste redner von der fdp
fraktion gleich marco buschmann der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der liberalen und dann wie es üblich ist
hat also jeder immer nur fünf minuten
rederecht es gibt nicht die möglichkeit
zwischen fragen zu stellen
es gibt keine abstimmung am ende der
aktuellen stunde
wenn sie sich fragen was hier abgestimmt
wird die federführung ist strittig wo
also diese verschiedenen anträge hier
weiter beraten werden in welchen
ausschuss das sind letztlich technische
fragen kommt es in diesen ausschuss
kommt es in jenen ausschuss
verkehrsausschuss umweltausschuss wo es
ein solches thema co2 reduktion bei pkws
richtig wahrscheinlich in beiden
ausschüssen aber dann ist die frage wer
hat die federführung wer liegt vorne wer
macht die vorgaben
diese dinge müssen in einem plenum eben
halt abgestimmt werden bundestags
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki da hier
die sitzung geleitet gehört auch in dem
verein in der schnellsprecher zudem da
hat sich was wahrscheinlich gestern
geäußert auch schäuble gehört
es geht schnell bei ihm jetzt also die
aktuelle stunde der masterplan migration
marco buschmann für die fdp fraktion hat
das wort geschäftsführer der fdp
bundestagsfraktion dr marco buschmann
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der verlauf dieser sitzungswoche hat
gezeigt wie akut diese aktuelle stunde
in wahrheit ist ich habe sie am montag
beantragt und da war das bild dieser
bundesregierung schon chaotisch und
eigentlich für die lage heute einige
tage später fehlen einen im deutschen
die richtigen worte denn das wort chaos
kennt im deutschen keine steigerungsform
es ist doch so seit dem herbst 2015
bestimmtes thema flucht migration und
asyl die deutsche politik es zieht alle
aufmerksamkeit alle kraftanstrengungen
dieser großen koalition auf sich und
dann hat doch die bevölkerung einen
anspruch auf eines dass sie endlich
einmal hört was ist der plan um das
thema endlich in den griff zu bekommen
stattdessen stattdessen hören wir seit
2015 2016 2017 und 2018 immer weitere
formelkompromisse statt eines klaren
konzepts und dann plötzlich kommt die
große ankündigung
da wird der eindruck erweckt jetzt kommt
der große wurf eigentlich hat man einen
plan gefunden
es ist sogar ein masterplan und dann
und dann bekommen wir ganz beiläufig in
einem fernsehinterview mit dass dieser
masterplan offenkundig noch nicht mal
mit der regierungschefin abgestimmt ist
dann lesen wir in den zeitungen drei
tage nachdem dieser plan eigentlich
schon der öffentlichkeit präsentiert
worden sein sollte dass dieser plan dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden der
mehrheitspartei im hause noch gänzlich
unbekannt ist das ist das schwächste
regierungs management dass dieses haus
je gesehen hat und man kann es dem
bürger nicht verübeln dass sie sich an
den kopf fassen das sorgt für frust und
enttäuschung in der bevölkerung keine
regierung die zu diesem top thema nicht
in der lage ist einen klaren plan
vorzulegen darf sich nicht wundern dass
die menschen immer verärgerter reagieren
und die antwort die das grundgesetz auf
eine solche lage gibt es doch eindeutig
da kann sich auch die spd nicht aus der
verantwortung stehlen denn die
bundesregierung entscheidet als
kollegialorgan artikel 65 des
grundgesetzes ist klar über
meinungsverschiedenheiten wird im
kabinett entschieden entweder durch
beschluss oder durch
richtlinienkompetenz und ich fordere die
regierung endlich auf die streitfragen
zu lösen entweder durch beschluss oder
durch richtlinienkompetenz denn dieses
bild das sie abgegeben
es wird ja nicht nur ein schlechtes
licht auf sie das könnte uns herzlich
egal sein es wirft ein schlechtes licht
auf die fähigkeit demokratischer
institutionen mittlerweile insgesamt die
bevölkerung verliert doch die geduld und
zunehmend das vertrauen das wir hier in
der lage sind
für die probleme der zeit zu finden und
gerade bei diesem thema hat sich die
sprengkraft in europa doch schon gezeigt
ein ganzer mitgliedstaat mit dem
vereinigten königreich ist durch die
falsche behandlung dieses themas aus der
eu heraus gesprengt worden und deshalb
müssen sie doch endlich sich des themas
vernünftig annehmen und deshalb ist es
ohne weiteres küste ist doch ohne
weiteres klar sein sich auf wenigstens
eine handvoll punkte zu einigen wir sind
ja hier konstruktiv unterwegs und machen
vorschläge sorgen sie endlich dafür dass
man kriminelle und gefährde schneller
abschieben kann
es ist doch unerträglich dass der nrw-
integrationsminister joachim stamp den
leibwächter von osama bin laden nicht
abschieben kann weil es einen
rechtlichen und tatsächlichen problemen
mangelt man muss oft
rückführungsabkommen haben braucht pass
ersatzpapiere die bundespolizei sollte
den ländern helfen das wäre jetzt das
gebot der stunde denn natürlich wollen
wir menschen in not helfen aber wir
wollen nicht der rückzugsort für die
gefährder der ganzen welt werden
sorgen sie dafür dass wir endlich eine
regelung für altfälle bekommen wir haben
heute die situation dass gut
ausgebildete migranten das reha heute
die gesetzestreue sind und ihr geld hier
verdienen können dass wir den zum teil
keine vernünftigen aufenthaltstitel
beschaffen können und dann kommen wir
sogar dazu dass wir die teilweise
abschreiben müssen was für ein irrsinn
gegen unsere volkswirtschaftlichen
eigeninteressen sorgen sie dafür dass
wir die neue schnelle aufenthaltstitel
beschaffen können bei den alt
sorgen sie dafür dass die löcher in der
balkanroute gestoppt werden sorgen sie
dafür dass wir endlich ein vernünftiges
dublin-abkommen bekommt wohl nicht
einige wenige die gesamte last schultern
müssen und schließlich sorgen sie dafür
dass wir schnell eine vernünftige
ertüchtigt und gut ausgestattete
grenzschutzagentur frontex bekommen und
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt denn das
wirklich über nacht geschehen wird es
auch möglich sein müssen
stichprobenartig an grenzen kontrollen
durchzuführen und dass diese
bundesregierung sich dazu nicht
durchringen kann zeigt dass ihr
koalitionsvertrag nicht nur auf sein
wort ist sondern dass er auf treibsand
steht herzlichen einmal gepusht mann war
dass der hier gesagt habt seit drei
jahren beschäftige das thema flüchtlinge
und integration die deutsche
innenpolitik und es geschehe viel zu
wenig nach ihm jetzt mathias middelberg
sprecher für innen und heimat der cdu
csu fraktion
herr buschmann ich schätze sie sonst
wirklich sehr herr kollege
aber was sie jetzt vorgetragen haben das
war doch etwas billig und ein bisschen
dünn
das sage ich ihnen ganz ehrlich
sie haben zu recht gesagt das thema
flucht flüchtlinge ist ein kernthema
seit jahren ist auch für uns ein
kernthema und deswegen ist es auch gut
so deswegen ist es auch gut so dass wir
uns intensiv damit befassen und wenn es
auch probleme und streitfragen unter uns
selbst gibt dass wir das dann auch
intensiv aufarbeiten
das ist nur gut so und was den plan
angeht den sie vermissen den haben wir
in unserem koalitionsvertrag
und wenn es darüber hinaus weitere
maßnahmen gibt ihm notwendig sind dann
müssen wir die während der
regierungszeit auch ein oder nach
steuern
insofern ist der plan den horst seehofer
vorlegen wird ein umfassender plan und
das finde ich das finde ich mal sehr
lobenswert es ist nämlich dann
wahrscheinlich der erste wirklich
integrierte plan wie wir mit dem thema
migration und integration insgesamt
umgehen er erfasst die ganze palette vom
thema
die bekämpfung der ursachen wie gehen
wir mit run sieht ländern um wir nun wie
lösen wir die europäischen fragen wie
machen wir es in deutschland bis zum
thema integration und der buschmann sie
haben das ja nett gesagt und sagen hier
würde nichts passieren die arbeiten doch
schon längst an den themen wenn sie
heute früh ein sie heute früh hier
geblieben wären nach der debatte über
die parteienfinanzierung hätten sie
damit die debatte die abschließende
debatte über das familiennachzugs
gesetzt mitbekommen das ist der erste
schritt den wir hier ganz konkret
unternehmen zum thema ordnung steuerung
der zuwanderung und der nächste ist
schon im verfahren nämlich weitere
sichere herkunftsstaaten die
maghreb-staaten und dazu georgien das
ist bereits in der ressortabstimmung des
horst seehofer schon längst eingeleitet
und der nächste schritt war wird konkret
eben gehandelt in der nächste schritt
der schon auf der bahn ist das sind die
anker zentren so und da ist es nun so
dieser anker zentren werde ja erkennbar
dazu beitragen dass die asylverfahren
optimiert und beschleunigt werden
wie die einigermaßen billig und gerecht
denkenden land die haben das jedenfalls
erkannt und die haben sich auch bereit
erklärt dass sie an diesem pilotvorhaben
teilnehmen
es gibt aber ein paar die das irgendwie
noch nicht so richtig begriffen haben
und dazu gehört ihr integrationsminister
herstammt in nrw der alles unternimmt
in diesem thema um in diesem thema
dagegen zu laufen so und wenn man das
jetzt und da bin ich jetzt gerade bei
herrn stammt den sie ja ebenso lobend
erwähnt haben wir haben hier in der
letzten woche die regierungsbefragung
mit unserer bundeskanzlerin gehabt da
hat sie darüber informiert wie die
situation in afghanistan aussieht nach
der neueren einschätzung des außenamtes
dass das jetzt abschiebungen nach
afghanistan ermöglicht das erste was ich
von ihrem integrationsminister in nrw
gehört habe dazu waren wieder bedenken
aus welchen gründen das dann nicht
möglich sei ja es war ein
einschränkungen
sie haben eben von uns handlungen
erfordert handeln im konkreten fall das
ist genau das was sie ihren
fdp-ministern mit auf den weg geben
müssen sie müssen sich als erstes an die
eigene nase fassen
hier geht es um konkrete fakten unter
liefern wir familien ich habe ich
erwähnt sichere herkunftsstaaten habe
ich ihnen genannt anker zentrum habe ich
genannt
das verbindet sich mit den themen
sachmitteln bezug residenzpflicht das
sind für uns weitere kernthemen was wir
weiter auf den weg bringen werden sind
optimierungen beim thema abschiebehaft
und ausreise gewartet haben damit sich
leute eben nicht mehr den abschiebungen
entziehen können
wir werden auch die ausweisung würden
bei sozialbetrug drogen belegten
drogendelikten und bei missbräuchlichem
handel mit flüchtlings dokumenten
absenken
beim thema bearbeiten wir im moment
konkrete probleme auf aber bei aller
kritik am was sage ich auch mal hier ist
die lage unterdessen dramatisch besser
geworden wir hatten früher monate lange
verfahren
wir haben jetzt verfahren die sind nach
drei
beendet wer als flüchtling jetzt in
unser land kommt hat nach weniger als
drei monaten seinen bescheid und als
letzten punkt möchte ich ihnen nennen
das thema integration
hier werden wir die mittel weiter
erheblich aufstocken nach dem prinzip
fördern und fordern
wir haben 2016 dafür 510 millionen
aufgewandt
in diesem jahr werden es 610 millionen
sein und eingestellt für den nächsten
haushalt haben wir 765 millionen das
sind steigerungsraten von 20 und 25
prozent über die jahre gerechnet das ist
konkretes handeln und das hat bisher
dazu geführt dass jeder fünfte
flüchtling der seit 2015 zu uns gekommen
ist jetzt in
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung ist wenn wir das zum
schluss zu tun wir im bereich migrations
und integrationspolitik dann könnte ich
ihnen hier noch eine halbe stunde lang
konkretes nicht wieder zum trotz
mathias middelberg war das cdu csu
fraktion der hier gesagt hat wir
arbeiten an den themen auch beispiele
angeführt hat gleichwohl hat diese
aussage für gelächter gesorgt nachdem
jetzt gottfried kurios sprecher für
innenpolitik der fdp- fraktion sehr
geehrter präsident gerd abgeordnete bei
der grenzöffnung wurde sehenden auges
voll auf risiko gefahren der verluste
sicherheit einfach einkalkuliert der
fall susanna zeigt beispielhaft den
maximal schaden der durch winkel kultur
ein hohn wenn frau merkel uns erzählt
der mord sei eine aufforderung an uns
alle die integration sehr ernst zu
nehmen
der mörder war als abgelehnter
asylbewerber ohnehin kein fall für
integration sondern abzuschieben
aber sie
selbst ein mord ist nur anlass für sie
ihre abwegigen dortmund zu propagieren
sie lässt unberechtigte personen
unerkannter identität rein vergewaltiger
mörder terroristen inklusive und wir
sollen uns verantwortlich fühlen nicht
wir haben zu handeln die verursacherin
muss endlich verantwortung übernehmen
und zurücktreten
ein staat der seine bürger nicht schützt
aber sie zwingt betrüger zu alimentieren
wer illegal die grenze übertritt ist
betrüger wer ohne papiere kommt will das
deutsche volk betrügen dieser betrug ist
raub ist gewalt ist kriminalität und
wehrleute an der papiere reihen lässt
leistet beihilfe ist mittäter jeder darf
sich doch jetzt fragen merkels ist mir
egal ob ich schuld an den migranten
bilden jetzt sind sie halt da meint das
auch ist mir egal ob die schuld am
schicksal der mädchen bin jetzt sind sie
halbtot wann ist endlich schluss mit
diesem wahnsinn mit dieser allzu oft
tödlichen willkommenskultur
da wird ein millionenheer ausgeprägter
junger männer ins land gelassen den
frauen als und übergriffs
objekte gelten wenn sie sich nicht der
islamischen unterdrückung skulptur an
bequemen gelernte frauenverachtung aber
ist programmierter frauenmord deshalb
beim kampf braucht nicht mehr
bauarbeiter sondern weniger
scheinasylanten seit 2005 10
seit 2005 ging es doch nur noch um den
anschein von bearbeitung teilweise hatte
patient kinderdörfer zu errichten die
bürger zu täuschen durch angeblich
bewältigte fallzahlen hinter denen aber
gar keine seriöse bearbeitungsstand
erscheinen des antragsstellers braucht
nicht das gewünschte ankreuzen geht
schneller identitätsnachweis braucht
nicht noch schneller papiere braucht
nicht vereinigte dolmetscher braucht es
nicht ausgebildet entscheider braucht
auch nicht alles ganz nach merkels motto
aus illegalen legale machen
ein amt nicht für geldwäsche nein für
hauptsache der wahlkampf 17 würde
ungestört laufen dem wurden sorgfalt und
sicherheit geopfert heute müssen wir
sagen auch menschenleben merkel gibt zu
das kanzleramt sie selbstverantwortlich
ein allzu billige sword wenn man dann
den stuhl nicht räumt wenn die koalition
und jährlich 200.000 migranten
aufzwingen will braucht 200 anders sind
und der minister hat schwierigkeiten
sechs pilot zentren zu schaffen
da geht nichts schneller örtliche
konzentration schafft nicht mehr
verwaltungsrichter
da wird nicht besser abgeschoben ohne
erzwungene residenzpflicht tauchen die
einfach ab es ist nicht der job der
bundespolizei die müssten die grenze
kontrollieren die leute erst gar nicht
reinlassen und september 15 gab es
natürlich keine humanitäre
ausnahmesituationen die leute waren in
ungarn in sicherheit und lange vorher
denen ging es um kalte vorteilsnahme im
staat mit dem westen sozialsystem die
ganze sogenannte willkommenskultur ist
inhuman mit demselben geld hilft man 100
mal effektiver vor ort und zwar den
wirklich armen und wo herr seehofer nur
bereits registrierte zurückreisen will
also nicht mal das rechtlich gebotene
fordert darstellt merkel sich schon quer
und erzwingt die ewige fortsetzung ihrer
sogenannten ausnahme entscheidung also
dauer überflutung durch illegale herren
seehofers vorschlag ist aber völlig
ungenügend die betrüger werden sich
einfach nicht mehr vor erreichen
deutschlands registrieren lassen
aber frau merkel uns sogar erzählen ihre
gänzlich offene grenze sein vorrangiges
europäisches recht was für ein unsinn
dublin 3 ist europäisches recht gerade
da ist der erste zutritt staat zuständig
und nicht deutschland
danach müssten sogar alle zurückgewiesen
werden sie kommen über sichere
drittstaaten aus einem anderen erst
zutritts land dublin anzuwenden ist kein
nationaler alleingang nationaler
alleingang war merkels handstreich im
september 5
zeit meine damen und herren zeit für den
masterplan zur zurückweisung einer
illegal agierenden kanzlerin zwei
drittel der bürger wollen die
grenzschließung sofort appellieren an
sie als ihre repräsentanten werden sie
ihrer verantwortung für das land gerecht
entfernen sie diese frau aus dem amt
wählen sie sie abspringen sie die
fesseln der parteidisziplin und den
würgegriff dieser politik unendlichen
schaden schützen sie das leben der
bürger rechten die den rechtsstaat
befreien sie das land von dieser politik
geräte von gottfried guru für die afg
war das nach ihm jetzt von der
bundesratsbank der berliner senator für
inneres und sport andreas geisel der der
spd angehört
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren für mich ist klar wer des
schutzes und der hilfebedarf bedarf
menschen die zu uns kommen die des
schutzes und der hilfe bedürfen die
werden diesen schutz und diese hilfe bei
uns auch finden
klar ist aber auch diejenigen bei denen
rechtskräftig festgestellt wurde dass
sie dieses schutzes und diese hilfe
nicht bedürfen müssen unser land wieder
verlassen
dazu bekennen sich die innenminister der
spd geführten länder ganz ausdrücklich
wir müssen den rechtsstaat
handlungsfähig machen und stehen in der
verantwortung das auch zu zeigen
so sind die spd-innenminister in der
vergangenen woche zur
innenministerkonferenz nach kritik
gefahren und wir wollten vom
bundesinnenminister dort hören wie er
mit einheitlichen standards rückführung
aus deutschland verbessern möchte wie er
sich die konkrete ausgestaltung der im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbarten anker
zentren vorstellt nun wir sind mit einer
gewissen irritation aus quedlinburg
zurückgekommen weil wir nur wenig
konkretes hören konnten
so ähnlich geht es mir übrigens auch bei
der heutigen bundestagsdebatte wir
debattieren hier über einen plan mit 63
punkten von denen uns 62 punkte
offiziell noch unbekannt sein
die antwort die antwort der anker
zentren bis zu 1500 asylbewerber an
einem standort zu beherbergen
beantwortet die probleme die wir sehen
zumindest nicht ich will ihnen die lage
im land berlin schilder und derzeit
haben wir etwa 12.000 menschen in der
stadt die vollziehbar ausreisepflichtig
sind
davon haben 6000 menschen eine
längerfristige geduld und beispielsweise
eine ausbildungs duldung oder aus
humanitären gründen wegen krankheit und
ähnliche weitere 4.000 duldungen stehen
aber an wegen anhängigen verfahren beim
verwaltungsgericht oder beim
oberverwaltungsgericht es sind
abgelehnte asylbewerber die gegen die
bescheide geklagt haben
was sind also die wirklichen probleme
bei der rückführung die wir sehen
erstens ist das die beschaffung von
passersatz papieren
zweitens ist die mangelnde bereitschaft
der heimatländer ihre staatsbürger
wieder aufzunehmen
dafür brauchen wir rückführungsabkommen
drittens ist es die mangelnde qualität
der bands bescheide diese mangelnde
qualität der baubescheid ist dafür
verantwortlich dass wir die vielzahl der
klagen haben und auch verantwortlich für
die dauer dieser klageverfahren und
viertens der vierte grund sind die
derzeit noch unzureichenden rückführung
des kapazitäten die antworten des
bundesinnenministers gehen zumindest
diese probleme nicht wirklich an man
kann auch sagen der bundesinnenminister
bietet uns lösungen für probleme die wir
eigentlich gar nicht haben und auch da
und auf der anderen seite gibt es für
unsere ungelösten fragen für die
probleme die wir wirklich haben noch
keine überzeugenden antworten
meine damen und herren
wir müssen die asylverfahren
grundsätzlich beschleunigen das ist
richtig ob dies aber dadurch erreicht
wird dass man bis zu 1500 menschen an
einem ort unterbringt davon bezweifeln
die erfahrungen die wir in berlin mit
tausenden flüchtlinge auf engstem raum
im flughafengebäude tempelhof gemacht
haben sind hier nicht vorbildhaft alle
mit asylfragen befassten behörden
zusammenbringen klingt gut aber den
beweis dass das tatsächlich zu mehr
effizienz für diesen beweis müssen erst
antreten
in einem stadtstaat wie berlin sind die
wege zwischen den beteiligten stellen
ohnehin kurz die zuständigen behörden
arbeiten hängen zusammen deshalb
erschließt es sich mir nicht dass die
vorgesehene einbindung der
verwaltungsgerichte in berlin zu einer
wesentlichen verfahrensbeschleunigung
beitragen kann der akten austausch
zwischen bank und verwaltungsgerichten
erfolgt hier schon in elektronischer
form
deshalb sage ich ihnen eine verbesserung
der qualität der bams bescheide wurde
die dauer der gerichtlichen verfahren
sicherlich wesentlich mehr beschleunigen
als ein umzug der asyl kann man in der
neu zu schaffenden verzeichnen also der
bundesinnenminister muss jetzt endlich
seine vorstellungen zur konkreten
ausgestaltung der anker zentren
erläutern
er will das in bilateralen gesprächen
mit den ländern mache so etwas auf der
innenministerkonferenz angekündigt sagt
ganz ausdrücklich wir stehen dem offen
gegenüber
meine damen und herren ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir vor allem diejenigen
abschieben müssen die unsere sicherheit
bedrohen
und das sind nicht im moment die
schutzsuchenden aus allen krisenregionen
dieser welt sondern sind vor allem
islamistische gefährder der fall amri
hat gezeigt wie mobil und
länderübergreifend islamistische
gefährder agieren
ich sehe hier dringenden handlungsbedarf
das geltende aufenthaltsgesetz muss viel
konsequenter angewendet werden § 58 a
des aufenthaltsgesetzes ermöglicht die
herbeiführung beziehungsweise
durchsetzung einer ausreisepflicht von
gefährdern auf vereinfachten und
beschleunigten weg nach der
aktuellen regelungen erfolgt eine solche
anordnung grundsätzlich durch die
oberste landesbehörde aber auch das
bundesministerium des innern kann eine
abschiebe verordnung erlassen wenn ein
besonderes interesse des bundes besteht
und bislang sind anordnung nach § 58
aufenthaltsgesetz durch mehrere
bundesländer erlassen worden nicht
jedoch durch den bund die fälle der
länder niedersachsen und bremen im
vergangenen jahren gezeigt wie viele
langwierige gerichtsverfahren die
entsprechenden anordnung nach sich
ziehen und sich abhängig hier die
landesbehörden von der zuarbeit des
bundes sind
ich bin der meinung wenn die
maßgeblichen erkenntnisse beim bund
liegen die fälle vom generalbundesanwalt
bearbeitet werden also personen
bundesland übergreifend agieren sollte
zukünftig der bund verstärkt tätig
werden alle bisherigen verfahren haben
gezeigt dass die arbeit des bundes für
die durchsetzung der abschiebungen
entscheidend ist das land berlin plant
deshalb eine bundesratsinitiative mit
dem ziel den paragrafen 58
aufenthaltsgesetz zu ändern um die
zuständigkeiten des bundes bei der
abschiebung von gefährdern zu
konkretisieren und auszubauen
mit diesem gesetzlichen änderungen
können die länder und der bund noch
effektiver zusammenarbeiten und personen
die unsere sicherheit gefährden
konsequenter abschieben meine damen und
herren
meine damen und herren abschließen will
ich sagen
bei aller wichtigkeit der heutigen
diskussion
entscheidend für den erfolg in der asyl-
und flüchtlingspolitik sind nicht
abschiebung oder zurückweisung an den
grenzen
entscheidend auch unter
sicherheitsaspekten es gelingende
integration im inneren unseres landes
entscheidend entscheidend ist
europäische zusammenarbeit nicht
abschottung europa ist nicht das problem
europa ist die lösung
meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren ist kann nur eine
gemeinsame europäische lösung geben
eine abschottung deutschlands löst nicht
die probleme ist nur ein einfacher eine
einfache schlussfolgerung die bei der
aufzählung der genannten probleme ganz
klar zeigt das löst nicht die probleme
und es widerspricht außerdem dem
europäischen gedanken
wir müssen wir müssen gemeinsam schauen
wie wir die europäischen außengrenzen
sichern und ländern wie griechenland und
italien dabei unsere unterstützung zu
sichern
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich im senator
andreas kreisel war dass der hier als
berliner senator von der bundesratsbank
gesprochen hat und gesagt hat
der masterplan der biete eine lösung für
probleme die wir gar nicht haben es gab
übrigens viel applaus aus der
spd-fraktion als sich geisel gegen die
anker zentren ausgesprochen hat also ein
potenzieller konflikt in der großen
koalition jetzt ulla jelpke sprecherin
für innenpolitik der linksfraktion
wieder öffentlich bekannt ist
noch glaube ich dass alle fraktionen
über diesen plan informiert würden
wir erleben eine aufgeheizte debatte
ohne richtige grundlage und ich bin
davon überzeugt dass genau das geplant
war
der innenminister will ein aufgeheiztes
klima schaffen um sich in bayerischen
wahlkampf als scharfmacher in sachen
flüchtlingspolitik in szene zu setzen
und das auf kosten der schutz
berechtigten und das ist wirklich
unerträglich
dass er für diese verantwortungsvolle
verantwortungslose politik unterstützung
von der afg und der fdp erhält ist
wirklich bezeichnend für die ganze
rechte seite hier im haus und sie sind
sich in wahrheit in der sache völlig
einig sie wollen eine weitere massive
aushöhlung des flüchtlingsrecht sie
wollen zurückweisungen an den grenzen
und die kasernierte unterbringung von
flüchtlingen inhuman lagern
sie streiten doch hier nur noch darüber
ob diese insgesamt politisch umgesetzt
wird oder ob ein nationaler alleingang
unternommen wird und seine damen stellen
es ist völlig klar wer pauschale
zurückweisung fordert tritt nicht nur
die menschenwürde der schutzwürdigen mit
füßen sondern auch das deutsche und das
internationale recht
nehmen sie doch mal zur kenntnis dass
das geltende europarecht dazu sagen das
so genannte doping regeln schreiben
eindeutig vor wenn jemand asyl beantragt
muss es ein ordentliches verfahren geben
inklusive der möglichkeit rechtsmittel
einzulegen um festzustellen welche eu
staat zuständig für das verfahren ist
und deswegen kann man die betreffenden
logischerweise nicht einfach an der
grenze abweisen
das sagt im übrigen auch der leiter des
un flüchtlingswerks in hc heute in der
welt ich zitiere jedenfalls für die
dauer dieser prüfung muss die
betreffende person auch bleiben dürfen
im ersten quartal dieses jahres sind
3900 personen an
grenze zurückgewiesen worden nach
offiziellen angaben aber keine
asylsuchenden eben weil das nicht
zulässig wäre
und bevor der wahlkampf in bayern begann
hat auch der innenminister seehofer ganz
klar gesagt in den innenausschuss und in
den medien im oktober 19 2017 in einer
pressekonferenz ich zitiere die
zurückweisung an der grenze ist eine
hoch komplizierte angelegenheit
die eine reform des dublin verfahrens
voraussetzen würde zitat ende
und daran herr seehofer ändert auch
irgendwelche bilateralen abkommen mit
österreich nichts denn sie jetzt
ernsthaft mit zurückweisung anfang
schaffen sie genau jene herrschaft des
unrechts die sie vor geraumer zeit nur
frau merkel vorgeworfen haben und meine
damen und herren noch einige worte für
den sogenannten anker zentren die ja
teil des masterplans sein sollen der
name ist schon reine schönfärberei weil
es um inhumane lager anstalten geht in
denen flüchtlinge wie kriminelle
untergebracht werden das ist
menschenverachtend
ich kenne die vorbilder dieser lager die
sogenannten transitstrecken zentren
schon das wort ist schrecklich in
manching und in bamberg aus eigener
anschauen ich war gerade es sei dort
werden bis zu 1500 flüchtlinge ein
gefecht zum teil über zwei jahre lang
festgehalten mit residenzpflicht
arbeitsverbot unzureichender
medizinischer versorgung ohne
perspektive die menschen dort werden
in die verzweiflung getrieben wer das zu
regeln für alle flüchtlinge machen will
der hat nicht nur kein herz sondern
macht sich mit schuld an einer
schamlosen aushöhlung des asylrechts und
an einer massiven vergiftung des inneren
klimas in unserer gesellschaft von dem
streit innerhalb des lagers darf man
sich nicht täuschen lassen inhalt nicht
haben wir eine erschreckende koalition
aus cdu csu fdp und afd
die gemeinsam das asylrecht begraben und
dass ich komme zu letzten satz und das
vor dem hintergrund dass ist nur 2200
menschen nach deutschland kam letztes
jahr aber zum schluss mächtig sagen wir
brauchen kein europe frau kollegin
bittet ich bitte jetzt darum dass die
kollegin v bundestags-vizepräsident
kubicki hat nun zum zweiten mal hier das
mikro abgestellt rechtsradikale lösung
die kritik von ulla jelpke war mehr als
deutlich wie ihr jetzt viele bürger
bündnis 90 die grünen sprecherin für
migrations- und integrationsfragen ihrer
fraktion
meine damen und herren
was ist mit dir los humanistisches
europa du verfechterin der
menschenrechte der demokratie und der
freiheit
was ist mit dir los europa die heimat
von dichtern philosophen künstlern
musikern literaten
was ist mit dir los europa die mutter
von völkern und nationen mutter großer
männer und frauen die die würde ihrer
brüder und schwestern zu verteidigen und
dafür ihr leben hinzugeben wussten
vier wochen nach diesen worten von papst
francisco
franziskus steht dieses europa und auch
deutschland vor einer weichenstellung
meine damen und
es geht um den zusammenhalt in europa
das wurde hier deutlich um solidarität
aber auch um die aufrechterhaltung
universeller menschenrechte und um das
grundgerät grundgerüst unserer union es
geht darum ob die europäischen staaten
in der lage sind gemeinsam probleme zu
lösen meine damen und herren
die csu hat in dieser woche gezeigt mit
ihrem selbsternannten heimat minister
dass sie lieber den weg der achse der
willigen gehen will mit den
rechtspopulisten in europa meine damen
und herren da machen wir nicht mit
sie verspielen damit liegt die liga
spielen damit nicht nur ihre
glaubwürdigkeit sondern sie beweisen
auch ihre unfähigkeit für deutschland
verantwortung zu übernehmen
als land für das humanität
menschenrechte und das höchste gut der
europäische gedanke steht sie waren
keine probleme lösen herr seehofer
das wurde diese woche deutlich sie
wollen wahlkampf in berlin für bayern
machen
und mit dieser angst die absolute
mehrheit am 14 oktober in bayern zu
verlieren stürzen sie nicht nur
deutschland sondern auch europa damit in
eine krise
und das ist unverantwortlich aber dann
geht es immer nur um die sache wenn dem
doch so tatsächlich so ist dann erinnere
ich an und wir haben es heute morgen
gehört beim parlamentarischen frühstück
erinnere ich an diesen tagen an die
aquarius eine verzweifelte
rettungsmission die vor den küsten
europas versucht 629 menschen darunter
123 unbegleitete minderjährige elf
kinder und sieben schwangere frauen an
einen sicheren hafen zu bringen
sehen sie worum es geht es geht um
menschen und der bayerische
ministerpräsident stellt sich hin und
spricht von asyl tourismus die finden
das widerlich und beschämend
sie haben eine verantwortung und wir
sehen an keiner stelle dass sie dieser
gerecht werden
markus söder hat gestern gesagt was
richtig ist muss man vertreten dann mal
los denn richtig ist die achtung der
menschenwürde
richtig ist der europäische gedanke die
solidarität und richtig ist unser
grundgesetz
sie marschieren gerade in die gegen
entsetzte richtung alle miteinander das
grundrecht auf asyl und die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention ist folge zweier
schrecklicher weltkriege infolge zweier
schrecklicher weltkriege entstanden und
sie sind dabei dieses in unserer
verfassung verankerte grundrecht in
frage zu stellen haben sie nichts
gelernt da machen wir nicht mit meine
damen und herren
und auch ein angeblicher maßen
das wurde ja deutlicher mittelberg
scheint im jahr zu canon bringt tiefe
einschnitte in die grundrechte mit die
maßnahmen die wir schon kennen und der
mittelberg ich sage warum machen sie
keinen masterplan integration
herr minister sie haben es doch selber
im innenausschuss gesagt sie sind auch
der minister für integration wo bleibt
der masterplan für integration den wir
so dringend brauchen und noch ein wort
vögel auch zur spd
das muss ich tun weil ich fünf jahre
wirklich gut mit ihnen
zusammengearbeitet hat in niedersachsen
in den letzten fünf jahren
ich darf sie daran erinnern dass sie
hier auch mitregieren von der union ein
ende des theaters zu fordern drama oder
tragödie das wissen der bis heute nicht
das klingt nicht nur passiv sondern auch
recht hilflos sie sitzen nicht im
publikum sie sitzen am kabinettstisch
also wo waren sie gestern wo waren sie
als die kanzlerin den abschiebestopp
nach afghanistan so kurz weg gewischt
hat und manchmal frage ich mich wo waren
sie bei den koalitionsverhandlungen sie
haben verantwortung übernommen liebe spd
dann fühlen sie diese auch gefälligst
aus was die csu hier vorgelegt hat ist
ein bruch des koalitionsvertrages wenn
sie ihrer verantwortung gerecht werden
wollen dann belasten sie es nicht nur
bei worthülsen wie heute morgen auch
morgenmagazin
[Applaus]
zum schluss ich möchte vielleicht doch
noch mit den worten von frau dr anita
lasker wallfisch die
holocaust-überlebende enden weil sie
hier vor fünf monaten zum tag des
gedenkens an die opfer des
nationalsozialismus hier in diesem hohen
hause gesprochen hat die welt ist voller
flüchtlinge herr präsident ich zitiere
für uns haben sich die grenzen damals
hermetisch geschlossen und nicht wie
hier geöffnet da brauchen sie gar nichts
zu lachen frau kollegin betragen dieser
unglaublich generösen mutigen
menschlichen geste die hier gemacht
wurde
das ist ganz einfach gift und letzten
endes vergiftet man sich selbst es
bleibt die hoffnung dass der verstand
sieht vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
ich rede von filiz polat war das bündnis
90 die grünen die hier namentlich dem
innenminister vorgeworfen hat dass er
für die wahl in bayern deutschland und
europa in eine krise stürzen und die
gilt für alle gleichermaßen hoffe die
grünen oder die bundestags-
vizepräsident kubicki
der besteht hier auf die einhaltung der
redezeit fünf minuten für jeden der
nächste der jetzt fünf minuten am
mikrofon hat ist der website cdu/csu de
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren der letzte redebeitrag
hat so ein eindruck erweckt als ob wir
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion uns
nicht die flüchtlinge und deren lage zu
herzen nehmen ich betone aber an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich für die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion steht außer frage
dass deutschland sich zu den menschen
bekannt die verfolgt werden
punkt 1.2 andererseits muss es aber doch
auch unser anspruch sein
die migration in unser land zu ordnen zu
steuern
und auch zu begrenzen vor allen dingen
sicherzustellen dass die asylverfahren
auch ordnungsgemäß und rechtmäßig
ablaufen obwohl wir in den letzten drei
jahren das sollte man nicht kleinreden
gesetzlich sehr viel auf den weg
gebracht haben auch um die verfahren zu
ordnen und zu beschleunigen
die integration zu verbessern ist unser
land an die grenzen gestoßen das muss
man erkennen die massenzuwanderung der
jahre 2015 und 2016 hat in vielen
bereichen unserer gesellschaft zu
verwerfungen geführt und auch und gerade
diese politik im bereich der asylpolitik
hat dazu geführt dass der
rechtspopulismus und der
rechtsradikalismus in unserem land einen
derartigen aufschub bekommen hat und
deshalb hängt die positive entwicklung
unseres landes ganz wesentlich von einer
gelungenen asylpolitik ab die die
menschen auch mitnimmt und deshalb ist
ein umfassender und auch vernetzte
ansatz her richtig und ich bin auch
dankbar den bundesinnenminister dass er
einen masterplan vorgelegt hat wundere
mich nur dass ein landesinnenminister
den inhalt kritisiert obwohl man gar
nicht kennt also das hat mich vorhin
wirklich verwundert wir müssen
europäisch international aber auch
national vorgehen und ein kernbereich
ist in jedem fall die geordnete
migration nach deutschland
auch sein kann auch wenn manche frage im
raum stehen und vier müssen wir auch
sehen das föderale gefüge hat uns nicht
immer genutzt und auch da setzt der
masterplan an
der vorliegende masterplan hat 63 punkte
und lediglich ein punkt war in den
letzten tagen in der diskussion
zurückschiebung im grenznahen raum gemäß
§ 18 asylgesetz meine damen und herren
an von 2016 habe ich mit 43 unions
kollegen gefordert dass maßnahmen in der
an der grenze umgesetzt werden
grenzpolizeiliche und deshalb können sie
sicherlich nachvollziehen
ich habe große sympathie auch für diesen
einen punkt
aber man darf es nicht überspannen
wir können nicht jeden an der grenze
zurückweisen man hört in den letzten
tagen ja die merkwürdigsten ausführungen
natürlich sind rechtsvorschriften da
unbegleitete minderjährige
familienbindung systemische mängel in
einem anderen land da dürfen wir nicht
zurückweisen aber wir können es doch
niemandem erklären wer bereits ein
anerkannter asylbewerber ist wer
woanders ein asylantrag gestellt hat
wenn nach dublin bereits zurückgeführt
ist steht wieder vor der türe und lässt
wird eingelassen das geht nicht und das
muss auch verändert werde
und letztlich müssen wir vermeiden und
da brauchen wir keine belehrung von der
afg die sowieso eine ganz falsche
richtung gehen dass die asylbewerber
sich das land nicht aussuchen können
sondern dass wir als politik als
gesellschaft entscheiden wer zu uns
kommt denn anderenfalls entstehen auch
neue anziehungs- effekte bull effekte
mit neuen problemen
das problem ist zu lösen aber nicht
binnen weniger tage und ein akuter
handlungsdruck ist auch gar nicht da wir
hatten 2015 800.000 menschen die zahl
des letztes jahrhundert 86.000
runtergegangen
dieses jahr voraussichtlich 165000 in
klammern natürlich immer noch zu hoch
aber es ist kein grund jetzt in panik zu
verfallen und alle politischen regeln
über bord zu werfen
wir müssen für die zukunft gewappnet
sein eine situation wie 2015 darf sich
nicht wiederholen und die
bundeskanzlerin hat in ihren vorhaben
mit den betroffenen eu staaten
bilaterale vereinbarungen zur
rückübernahme zu treffen unsere volle
unterstützung verdient und am ende ist
klar
sollten die europäischen partner sich
gänzlich verweigern müssen wir neu
denken und national nach steuert vielen
dank
als nächstes die rede von der website
sollte sich die europäischen partner
verweigern dann müsse man in neue denken
hat er hier gesagt hat er hier
angekündigt könnte man auch sagen weiter
geht es mit lars herrmann für die afg
fraktion sehr geehrter herr präsident
meine damen und herren
der masterplan der bundesregierung und
insbesondere hier die geheimwaffe banker
zentren werden keine wesentlichen
änderungen in der katastrophalen
asylpolitik bringen zunächst es
festzustellen dass die einrichtung von
anker zentren in deutschland in der
mitte europas und damit im zentrum der
schengen-vertrag starten der vollkommen
falsche ansatz ist wenn illegale
migranten bei uns ankommen ist das kind
bereits in den brunnen gefallen nach
unserem grundgesetz sowie auch nach
europäischem recht war genau das nämlich
ausgeschlossen
es gibt nach es gibt nach der
derzeitigen rechtslage lno zwei
möglichkeiten zumindest halbwegs legal
in deutschland einen asylantrag zu
stellen nämlich wenn man per flugzeug
kommt oder aus der nord beziehungsweise
ostsee aus dem wasser steigt diese
strengen regeln sind keine erfindung
meiner fraktion sondern wurde doch von
ihnen hier genauso beschlossen
obwohl schengen und dublin von anfang an
nicht funktioniert haben wurde erst im
jahr 2015 das endgültige scheitern
dieser regelung für jedermann
offensichtlich das haben übrigens auch
fast alle sachverständigen bei der
öffentlichen anhörung des innenausschuss
am 16.4 2018 so gesehen
professor doktor team sagte
beispielsweise dazu ich zitiere wir
wissen alle dass die dublin regeln in
der praxis nicht funktionieren
der sachverständige gerald knaus äußerte
sich noch wesentlich deutlicher und ich
zitiere das merkwürdige am dublin system
war es hat nie funktioniert in den
letzten 20 jahren aber bis vor wenigen
jahren hat das niemanden wirklich
gestört gestört es war eine enorme
verschwendung von ressourcen
zitat ende nun wird laut masterplan fest
damit gerechnet dass die migranten durch
die bundespolizei an der grenze
festgestellt und kontrolliert werden da
muss ich fragen welche grenze welche
kontrolle
ich hoffe es sind damit nicht die der
zeigen schaufenster kontrollen meiner
kollegen gemeint die im augenblick an
den autobahnen zu österreich als
wahlkampfhelfer für die bayerische
landtagswahl missbraucht werden was was
tut nämlich stattfindet ist maximal ein
schlechtes theaterstück aber keine
grenzkontrollen
nun sollen dank der künftigen anderssein
trennen die abgelehnten asylbewerber
schnell in ihre herkunftsländer
zurückkehren
hört sich toll an wird jedoch im echten
leben nicht funktionieren ein
abgelehnter asylantrag bedeutet eben
nicht dass diese person automatisch das
land tatsächlich verlassen
trauriges beispiel hierfür der des
mordes an der 14-jährigen susanne aus
mainz dringend tatverdächtiger irakische
flüchtlinge ali b dessen asylantrag
bereits im dezember 2016 abgelehnt wurde
im dezember 2016
und noch ein beispiel im vergangenen
jahr wurden gerade einmal 17 tausend
personen abgeschoben
das ist die um die dublin-fälle
bereinigte zahl 17.000 aktuell aber
haben wir über 200.000 vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtige abgelehnte
asylbewerber in deutschland es gibt
jedoch bundesweit nur 400 abschiebehaft
plätze ich erinnere an dieser stelle
auch an die lächerlichen rück
übernahmeabkommen die beispielsweise mit
tunesien und marokko abgeschlossen
worden
und die krönung des ganzen die absolute
krönung wenn die inhaber einer duldung
lange genug durchhalten wird ihren
widerstand gegen die abschiebung auch
noch mit der erteilung einer
aufenthaltserlaubnis belohnt diese
errungenschaft haben wir übrigens der
rot grünen bundesregierung unter gerhard
schröder zu verdanken
der innenminister hofft nun darauf dass
die sogenannten dublin-fälle schnell in
das eu land überstellt werden können
welches nach dem dublin abkommen für den
asylbewerber eigentlich zuständig ist
lassen sie uns auch hier ein blick in
die realität werfen im jahr 2017 gab es
64 1276 solcher übernahme ersuchen von
deutscher seite an die dublin
vertragsstaaten tatsächlich wurden
jedoch nur 7102 personen daraufhin über
stellt also gerade einmal elf prozent
im gegenzug hat deutschland 8754
personen im dublin verfahren aus anderen
eu ländern wieder zurückbekommen diese
verheerende dublin bilanz mag auch der
grund dafür sein warum nun so vehement
darauf gedrängt wird den personenkreis
der dublin fälle direkt an der grenze
zurückzuweisen
so zumindest erstmal die theorie und
auch hier ein kurzer ausblick auf die
realität voraussetzung für eine
zurückweisung soll laut masterplan
nämlich sein dass die personen bereits
ein asylverfahren in einem anderen eu
land betreibt regelmäßig nur nachweisbar
in dem die person dort auch vorher
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wurde und
die fingerabdrücke im eurodac system von
italien griechenland spanien et cetera
ordnungsgemäß eingepflegt werden was
glauben sie denn wie sorgfältig hier die
südliche mitgliedsländer künftig
arbeiten werden und was glauben sie wie
lange es dauert bis das sich bei den
schleusern herumgesprochen hat sehr
geehrter herr innenminister an die
zentren machen in deutschland
deutschland schlichtweg keinen sinn
sie machen auch an den binnengrenzen
keinen sinn wenn er überhaupt gehören
solche zentren an die eu außengrenze
idealerweise jedoch in einen drittstaat
ansonsten wird aus dem masterplan ein
desaster plan
vielen dank
die rede von lars herrmann für die
fdp-fraktion minister rede ist jetzt die
lars castellucci spd-sprecher für
migration und integration seiner
fraktion
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen am mittwoch war
integrationsgipfeln im kanzleramt und
das war eine ziemlich bunte
veranstaltung mit vertreterinnen und
vertretern von migranten organisationen
kirchen religionsgemeinschaften und so
weiter mein eindruck ist die integration
von denen in deutschland ist ein
pappenstiel im vergleich zur integration
der csu in unserer bundesregierung
man kann gut finden oder man kann
schlecht finden was eine regierung tut
aber handlungsfähig muss sie sein
und ich fordere sie wirklich auf der
zirkus geht und schon mehrere jahre nur
unterbrochen durch die bundestagswahl
der gestrige tag das war wirklich ein
symbol vier stunden
sitzungsunterbrechung sie blockieren
dass wir hier vorankommen
das eine zumutung für den
koalitionspartnern unser land das geht
so nicht weiter
haben eben eine sondersitzung des
innenausschusses unterbrochen um zu
dieser debatte zu kommen
da geht es um die aufklärung der
vorfälle im bremer bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge herr
innenminister
ich habe den eindruck sie haben viele
baustellen da müssen sie nicht dauernd
neue aufmachen politik erschöpft sich
nicht im ausland kündigen wie man neue
pläne es soll bitte auch etwas umgesetzt
werden das steht jetzt auf der
tagesordnung
und zwar nicht irgendwann sondern das
was wir vereinbart haben entschuldigung
wir haben einen koalitionsvertrag auf
den machen wir denn so was
und da steht eine menge drin
insbesondere zum kapitel migration
flucht integration ist eines der
längsten kapitel darüber wurde lange
verhandelt und deswegen der
innenminister verhandeln sie
rückübernahmeabkommen nehmen sie den
herrn müller mit der da hinten sitzt der
soll nochmal mithelfen dass wer
kooperiert auch verdunste hilfe bekommt
das würde doch uns voran bringen
machen sie was der geisel hier
vorgetragen hat engagieren sie sich für
die abschiebung von gefährdern und
jammern sie nicht immer nur dass das
nicht funktioniert legen sie ein
einwanderungsgesetz vor weil doch
eindeutig ist bringen wir die illegale
migration bekämpfen wollen müssen
legale migration ermöglichen und so
weiter liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir hatten eigentlich eine erfolgreiche
woche wir haben sie so wichtige
reformvorhaben aus gleis gesetzt wir
haben die muster feststellungsklage
endlich menschen die sich allein
gelassen fühlen gegen große konzerne sie
können jetzt unterstützung habe weil
verbände für sie klagen können
wir haben die brücken teilzeit dass man
nicht in die sackgasse gerät im beruf
wenn man sich um seine eltern bei der
pflege kümmern will oder um die kinder
oder wir haben gleiche beiträge für
arbeitnehmer und der arbeitgeber bei der
krankenversicherung durch gesetz das
sind wirklich große schritte und der
rede darüber niemand weil sie immer
solche streite inszenieren über die
fragen über die wir jetzt wieder
diskutieren so verrutscht die diskussion
und die quittung werden sie bei der
bayerischen landtagswahl erhalten so und
zum schluss europa ich mache mir
wirklich sorgen wir alle zusammen in
europa machen heute etwa acht prozent
der weltbevölkerung aus und bin in einer
generation wird sich das absehbar
halbieren und meine damen und herren
wenn wir unsere art zu leben
freiheit demokratie menschenrechte wenn
wir diesen werten eine stimme geben
wollen dann nur wenn wir europa lernen
wieder mit einer stimme zu sprechen
und deswegen fordern sie das nicht
länger heraus wir brauchen ein
gemeinsames europa wir rufen heute nach
solidarität in europa waren längst lange
nicht solidarisch 2005 ist eine richtige
aber eine einsame entscheidung getroffen
worden und heute csu sollen wir wieder
isoliert handeln das gegenteil ist nötig
wir müssen in europa vertrauen aufbauen
und nicht vertrauen erneut zertrampelt
leider glaubt uns bei dem was ich jetzt
sage wenn ich das draußen aus
veranstaltung sagen wir kaum mehr ein
mensch weil sie ja sehen ein gipfel nach
dem andern scheitert oder ist ohne
fortschritt und das licht an leuten die
sie von der csu gerne zur klausurtagung
einladen oder mit denen sich der
innenminister trifft anstatt zum
integrationsgipfel zu gehen ich sage
ihnen klar passen sie auf statistiken
sagen nagel europas werden hier wird der
wurf dort unsere zahlkarten stehen
bereit für vernünftige lösung wir
brauchen eine humanitäre
flüchtlingspolitik wir müssen auch
konsequenzen bei der rückführung von
denen die kein bleiberecht haben wir
müssen mit unseren zusammen mit unseren
partnern zusammenarbeiten wir handeln
verantwortlich sie veranstalten
chaostage weiß ich muss von außen haben
wegen ihrer landtagswahl und das ist
nicht verantwortlich
deshalb verehrte kolleginnen kollegen
von der csu
heute muss man den satz mal sagen
deutschland zuerst lars castellucci über
das für die spd fraktion einen
frontalangriff das kann man kaum noch
anders sagen gegen den koalitionspartner
gegen die csu sie blockieren das geht so
nicht weiter chaos tage das waren worte
immerhin von jemandem der mit der csu in
der koalition ist bis die rednerin ist
jetzt linda teuteberg für die fdp
sprecherin für migrationspolitik ihrer
fraktion eine bemerkenswerte woche
hinter uns dazu hat mein kollege marco
buschmann alles notwendige gesagt doch
die lage ist zu ernst die probleme sind
zu groß als dass wir uns weiter mit dem
schwester kampf von cdu und csu
aufhalten könnten deutschland und europa
können nicht warten bis die union sich
wieder zusammengefunden hat wir haben
schon zu viel zeit verloren
wir haben als freie demokraten darum
heute einen vorschlag in der sache
gemacht
ein vorschlag der zeigt dass mit
vernunft beides zusammen geht eine
begrenzte zurückweisung an unseren
grenzen immer dann wenn ein
schutzsuchende bereits in einem anderen
eu-staat registriert ist dort anspruch
auf ein asylverfahren hat und
gleichzeitig
setzen wir auf mehr zusammenarbeit auf
intensive verhandlungen in europa weil
wir weil wir wissen die herausforderung
bei der migration werden wir nicht
allein lösen können eine nationale
lösung kann nur eine übergangslösung
sein
aber das ist natürlich nur eine der
vielen fragen die wir endlich
beantworten müssen und wo die koalition
die konflikte der union und auch die
lähmung der koalition lösungen immer
noch verhindern
wir müssen endlich mehr tun um die
probleme in den herkunftsländern zu
lösen
die fluchtursachen zu bekämpfen da geht
es nicht nur darum dass wir mehr geld
ausgeben sondern dass wir es auch
richtig ausgeben
die bundesregierung hat die ansätze für
die bekämpfung von fluchtursachen zwar
erhöht aber bisher kein schlüssiges
konzept vorgelegt wie man diese mittel
effizient einsetzt
und dann müssen wir in europa auch
endlich zu lösungen kommen seit drei
jahren ist wenig passiert fortschritte
sind kaum messbar
da muss es endlich voran geben mit einer
deutlichen deutlichen stärkung von
frontex einer engeren kooperation mit
unseren europäischen nachbarstaaten mit
vorgeschobenen asylzentren in denen
flüchtlinge direkt also beantragen
können mit einer entschlossenen
unterstützung für jene mitgliedstaaten
in denen besonders viele schutzsuchende
eintreffen
und nicht zuletzt müssen wir auch in
deutschland unsere hausaufgaben machen
die beschleunigung der asylverfahren und
zwar bei ohne vernachlässigung der
gründlichkeit der rechtsstaatlichkeit
ist überfällig und eine konsequente
rückführung wo immer möglich freiwillig
und wo nötig auch eine konsequente
abschiebung übrigens
ist die zügigkeit der verfahren gerade
auch im interesse der menschen mit
bleibeperspektive die wir dann umso
besser integrieren können und denen wir
eine perspektive geben können und zu
guter letzt müssen wir die einwanderung
nach deutschland insgesamt in ordnung
mit einem einwanderungsgesetz das diesen
namen verdient und herr kollege
castellucci da wird möglicherweise doch
umgekehrt auch ein schuh draus mehr
akzeptanz für legale migration erhöhen
will der muss auch entschlossen illegale
migration bekämpfen und vieles wäre da
längst möglich kam ein gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt zb zu den maghreb staaten als
sicheren herkunftsstaaten beschluss auch
durch die koalition bisher fehlanzeige
wir sind auch offen über anker zentren
zu diskutieren wir wollen aber auch mal
wissen was sie darunter verstehen ich
finde es bemerkenswert wie viele hier
von einem masterplan sprechender uns ja
gerade noch nicht vorgelegt wurde und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
brauchen lösungen arbeiten und für
wirkliche europäische lösungen reicht es
eben nicht diese immer nur pathetisch zu
beschwören
und wenn dublin drei unvollkommen ist
kommen wir zu einer besseren lösung
nicht durch bloße nichtanwendung von
dublin 3 wir wollen europa als raum der
freiheit der sicherheit und des rechts
stärken
und wenn es eine unvollkommene regelung
gibt dann müssen wir das interesse an
einer funktionierenden nachfolgeregelung
deutlich machen und vor allem auch
unsere partner davon zu überzeugen nicht
zu sagen ja was machen wir dann wenn die
sich nicht einlassen auflösungen dann
sehen wir danach mal weiter abwarten ist
keine lösung keine strategie wir bringen
übrigens unsere partner zum beispiel
nicht dazu an gemeinsamen lösungen zu
arbeiten wenn wir eine praxis etwa die
zurückweisung nach dublin drei die unser
nachbar frankreich anwendet als
rechtswidrig diffamieren und
dass die bundesrepublik mehr also wie
verfahren bearbeitet hat alle anderen eu
mitgliedstaaten zusammen das kann jeder
der verantwortung satish denkt nicht
belassen diesen zustand
es geht auch um gesamtstaatliche
verantwortung schade dass herr geisel
diese an mahnt aber mit keinem wort
erwähnt dass die länder berlin und
brandenburg keinerlei abschiebehaft
plätze etwa zur verfügung stellen ein
großes problem für die bundespolizei wir
wollen an lösungen arbeiten wir fordern
sie auf rufen sie einen migrations
gipfel ein auch mit ländern und kommunen
und wem es um die stabilität wirklich
dieses landes und europa geht der darf
sich nicht um politische debatte und
entscheidungen drücken vielen dank herr
zählt teuteberg war das für die fdp
fraktion du hier durchaus ihre
zusammenarbeit die zusammenarbeit die
kooperation ihrer fraktion angeboten hat
war ja jetzt michael kupfer cdu csu herr
präsident kolleginnen und kolleginnen
es ist nicht nur schäbig sondern jedes
mal wieder traurig zusehen zu müssen wie
die afd
die opfer schrecklichster taten für
ihren klamauk hier missbraucht es ist
glaube ich
es ist glauben und es ist angesichts
dieser vorgeschichte verdienstvoll dass
sich die fdp und anna auf die spd nach
kräften bemüht haben uns wieder
aufzuhalten
das war jetzt bei der fdp noch im
mittelmaß weil es ein schwieriges
schauspiel ich weiß das sieht doch gar
nicht so weit zumindest an vielen
stellen von unseren vorstellungen weg
liegen sie müssen natürlich heute was
anderes vor spielen aber aber die spd
hat da schon ein bisschen mehr
nachgelegt ihr habt dann auf den
kollegen castellucci hoffen er ist
normal immer für einen lacher gut
er hat jetzt natürlich auch wieder nur
die alten schallplatten hier ausgetragen
wobei ein guter witz war dabei der wegen
sagen den berliner zitieren
das war der ging ungefähr so der witz
die spd steht für konsequente
abschiebungen wie viel wir abschiebehaft
lädt sie haben sie in berlin
der kollege geißler der iss
vorsichtshalber schon mal gegangen der
sucht den abschiebe auf platz
wahrscheinlich
es ist weniger als eins kann ich ihnen
verraten nämlich null und und in dem
bereich zwischen 0 und einstellig werden
sicher auch ihre ergebnisse bei den
landtagswahlen die sie immer so
beschwören bewegen wenn sie so
weitermachen das kann ja an der stelle
auf jeden fall schon mal ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen der journalist
cube müller hat einen wahren satz gesagt
er hat gesagt wahrheiten den die
niemanden verärgern sind meist nur halbe
und zur ganzen wahrheit gehört meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen dass in
der asylpolitik der letzten jahre fehler
begangen worden sind und zur ganzen
wahrheit gehört auch und das ist noch
schlimmer im befund müssen wir uns
stellen dass sich in der frage der
asylpolitik die menschen in unserem land
und die politik auseinander gelebt und
mit dem masterplan asyl legen wir die
grundlage dafür dass wir den politischen
kurs mit den sorgen der menschen im land
wieder zusammenbringen das wir tempo und
höhe verstärken wo der kurs stimmt dass
wir den kurs justieren wo sich dinge
weiterentwickelt haben und dass wir den
kurs ändern und neu setzen wo dinge in
die falsche richtung gelaufen sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dazu
gehört dazu gehört das versprechen dass
wir die hilfsmöglichkeiten und die
hilfsbereitschaft der menschen in
unserem land dass die dass die
hilfsmöglichkeiten die uns die menschen
ermöglicht haben mit ihrer
hilfsbereitschaft dass wir sie
ausschließlich zur nothilfe nach dem
master not und nicht zur ungeprüften
verteilung von wohltaten einsetzen
dazu gehört auch dass wir exakt zwischen
flucht asyl und zuwanderung
unterscheiden
das ist eine ihrer großen
verständnisprobleme liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von den grünen
sie helfen niemandem wenn sie alles in
einem topf werfen wenn sie ihre
kapazitäten überschätzen an der falschen
stelle ein
jetzt sind sie das schlechteste helfer
es gibt immer noch einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens in unserem
land dass wir helfen wollen wo not am
mann ist aber wir dürfen die
hilfsbereitschaft unserer bevölkerung
nicht uminterpretieren indem wir daraus
einen willen zu einer ungebremsten
zuwanderung ableiten einen solchen
konsens gibt es in der gesellschaft
nicht dafür haben wir kein mandat zu den
versprechungen wird gehört auch dass wir
nur denjenigen die tür öffnen die bei
uns wirklich anspruch auf ein
asylverfahren haben und dass wir jene an
der grenze zurückweisung für die wir
nach europäische asylrecht nicht
zuständig sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das gilt
gerade für die frage der zurückweisung
der fälle die in einem anderen
mitgliedsland bereits vorstellig
geworden sind wir reden über 50 bis
60.000 fälle pro jahr
vieles ist kompliziert und schwierig
diese frage ist einfach sie ist
rechtlich klage löst sie ist politisch
noch klar gelöst weil sie in europa um
uns herum
an vielen stellen praktiziert wird
mittlerweile realität ist und deshalb
muss die zurückweisung an der grenze zum
maßnahmenpaket gehören wenn wir nicht
glaubwürdigkeit aufs spiel setzen nur
das sage ich ihnen an der stelle ganz
deutlich weil uns die leute bei uns die
leute nicht mehr kaufen würden dass wir
den willen und die kraft aufbringen
die schwierigen probleme zu lösen wenn
wir schon nicht einmal den willen
aufbringen des naheliegendste zu tun
davon liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
sage ich ihnen am schluss sind wir als
csu überzeugt wir sind überzeugt dass
die kursänderung und die vorgeschlagenen
maßnahmen richtig und dass sie nötig
sind für das land und die menschen die
uns ihre verantwortung an vertrauen
den letzten und in diesem sinne bitte
ich um verständnis dafür dass wir das
nicht davon abhängig machen können ob
sich da ein oder andere in der koalition
gut fühlt oder wie die umfrage meinen
oder anderen tag sind da müssen wir
etwas langfristiger denken und es würden
sie vielleicht verstehen wenn sie auch
einmal bereit während ford und wieder
hat er das mikro ausgestellt das ist
doch recht radikal hier was wolfgang
kubicki macht wer zu lange redet dem
nimmt er das wort michael kummer war das
in dieser aktuellen stunde die
einberufen worden ist von der
fdp-fraktion es geht um den masterplan
flüchtlings und integrations flüchtlings
und migrationspolitik
integrationspolitik ist soweit man weiß
kein teil dieses masterplans der ja aber
noch gar nicht publiziert ist wie in
gewisser weise haben die abgeordneten
hier über ein papier gesprochen dass sie
zumindest im detail gar nicht kennen das
aber gleichwohl bereit in dieser woche
für viel viel streit gesorgt hat ich
habe meine damen und herren unsere
übertragung aus dem deutschen bundestag
für heute für diese woche ist beendet es
war eine spannende politische woche eine
spannende sitzungswoche wir machen jetzt
weiter mit einem dokumentarfilm gewinne
ohne gier wirtschaften mit gewissen